well first of all we want to find the
planets like earth first like just even
finding those earth-like planets is a
billion-dollar endeavor billions of
dollars endeavor
and that's so hard because an earth is
so small
so less massive and so faint compared to
our sun
it's the proverbial needle in a haystack
but worse and
we need very sophisticated space-based
telescopes to be able to find these
planets and to look
look at them and see which ones have
water and which ones have signs of life
on them yeah the
the star shade project that you're part
of shade starship yeah this is probably
the most badass thing i've ever seen
right
you know what's interesting so what's
amazing about starshade is it was first
conceived in the 1960s
imagine that and revisited every decade
until now when we think we can actually
build it and star shade
is a giant specially shaped screen it is
about
there's different versions of it but
think about 30 meters in diameter
so you're blocking out the sun you're
effectively blocking out the star
yeah so that you can see the planet
directly and starshade
would have a spacecraft attached to it
and it would fly in space far away from
earth's gravity
and it would have to formation fly with
the space telescope
so the idea is that starshade blocks out
the starlight in a very careful way
and it has to block that starlight out
so that the planet
that is 10 billion times fainter than
the star that only the planet light
goes to the telescope yeah so
in formation meaning the telescope flies
and um as you give a presentation on
this but like it it would fly
like in um this is extremely
high precision endeavor yeah we had this
analogy like
asking a friend to hold up a dime five
miles away yeah
perfectly like at the perfect line of
sight with you yeah
and the shape of it is pretty cool i
mean uh i don't know exactly what the
physics of that like
what the optics are that require that
shape i can tell you
it turns out that if you block out a
star imagine blocking out a star with a
circle
circularly or a square shaped screen you
wouldn't actually be blocking it
because the star acts like a wave the
star light can act like a wave and it
would actually
bend around the edges of the screen and
so instead of blocking out the light
you're expecting to see nothing you
would see ripples
and the analogy that i love to give it's
like throwing a pebble in a pond
you get those ripples you get these
concentric ripples and they go out and
light would do something quite similar
you'd actually see ripples of light and
those ripples of light
they're actually way brighter than the
planet we'd be looking for
so they would introduce this noise
that's yeah noise and so this star shade
it's like a mathematical solution to the
problem of diffraction it's called
and this is what the first person who
thought about star shade in the 1960s
worked out the mathematical
shape or one solute one family of
solutions
and the idea is that when the star shade
this very special shape like a giant
flower
with petals when it blocks out the light
the light bends around the edges but
interacts with itself in a way to give
you a very very dark image
it would be like throwing a pebble in a
pond and instead of getting ripples
the pond would be perfectly smooth like
incredibly smooth to one part in 10
billion
and all the waves would be on the outer
edges far away from where you dropped
that pedal
pebble and so this camera would be able
to
uh this camera this telescope would be
able to
get uh get some signal from the planet
then yes and it would be hard because
the planet is so faint but with the star
out of the way the glare of that bright
bright bright star
with that out of the way then it becomes
a much more manageable task
so how do we get that thing out there
we're working with unlimited money okay
working with unlimited money um
we have some more engineering problems
to solve but not too many more we've
been burning down our so-called tall
pool list
and then we talked about what kind of
list we call it tall techno
technology tall pole it's the phrase
where
you have to figure out what are your
hardest problems and then break those
down to solve
so the star shade one of the really hard
problems was how do formation fly
at tens of thousands of kilometers it's
like wow
that is insane and the team broke that
down actually into a sensing problem
because of the star shade how do you see
the star shade precisely enough to to
control it
because if you're shining a flashlight
you know the beam spreads out
so the star shade has a beacon an led or
a laser it's going to spread out so much
by the time it gets to the telescope the
problem wasn't how do you tell the star
shade how to move around fast enough to
stay in a straight line
the problem was how do you how are you
able to sense it well enough so
problems like that were broken down and
money that came from nasa to solve
problems is
put towards solving it so we're we've
got through most of the hard problems
right now another one
was that star shade even though it's
looking at a star
light from our own sun could hit the
edges of the star shade
and bounce off into the telescope
believe it or not
and that would actually ruin it because
we're trying to see this tiny tiny
signal so then the question is how do
you make a razor thin edge
like those pedal edges would be like
have to be like a razor
and what materials can you so there's a
series of problems like that so
wow so there's a materials problem in
there some of them
and there's one so we almost finished
solving all those problems and then it's
just a matter of
building one and testing it in a full
scale size facility
and then building the telescope it's
just a matter of time to build
everything
and get it get it up for lunch so this
is
an easy close engineering yes this is an
engineering project
it's a real engineering project i
actually can tell you about two other
projects that are not mine
um i like to call starshade mine because
it was my project that i helped make it
mainstream
where that line is constantly shifting
when i started when i got this
leadership role on star shade
i remember telling people about it and
it was definitely not on the mainstream
okay line
it was on the giggle factor side of the
line and people would just laugh like
that's dead like you could never
formation fly
or they'd say why are you working on
that that's just so not it's not this is
so awesome
there's a there's a few things you've
done in your life and that's when i
first
saw starshine i was like what really
and then like it sinks in i mean it's
the same thing i felt with like elon
musk or certain people who do crazy
stuff
like this and then and they get they
actually make it work
i mean if you get started information
flying
to like together i mean how awesome
is that if you actually make that happen
even like from a robot i'm sorry from
the robotics perspective
even if it doesn't give us good data
that's just like a cool thing
to get out there and it's really
exciting really cool
you